if you want to have freedom in your life
the way to get to freedom is is through
discipline and you stop lying to
yourself that's when you can become who
you know you should be we can feel like
no one's ever been through what I've
been through and the world is hard for
me and easier for everyone else well the
reality is that's not true need
motivation watch a top ten with believe
nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being a kid who wanted to always be
a commando to spending 20 years in the
u.s. Navy SEALs and now teaches people
the leadership lessons that he learned
from the battlefield
he's jakka willing and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success volume 6
also if you want to know a Jocko and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confident series where every day for the
next 254 days I will send you in morning
video for free to help you build your
confidence - like the join is in the
description below people want to know
how to stop the laziness and they will
know how to stop the procrastination
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get discipline let's say you're the
most ultra motivated guy in the world
when that alarm clock goes off there's
at least 50% of the time where you just
that that soft little pillow is just
caressing your head and you want to stay
there and it takes discipline to go nope
I'm gonna get up out of this bed I'm
going to do what I'm supposed to do and
that discipline that you have at that
moment you win that fight that's a big
victory and then that that that pattern
will carry out throughout the day
because once you're up well now let them
up I might as well go work out because
I'm already up and I I feel good that I
got up out of bed and I won that battle
let me go win another battle I'm gonna
go get it done and then when you show up
at the office and there's someone that's
got a big box of doughnuts that they're
given away for free by the way so
they're just sitting it's almost like an
insult not to take them but when you've
already gotten up early you had the
disciplinary you already worked out you
had the discipline there and now you see
the box of doughnuts you're like no I'm
not gonna eat the doughnuts no no
doughnuts you're not gonna do it and
that discipline carries on throughout
the day so now you take that and you you
expand that out over a week in a month
and you end up with more discipline and
it starts with that simple act of
getting up and getting out of bed in the
morning we all want freedom right we all
want to have freedom we want we only
have financial freedom we want to have
more free time we don't have physical
freedom that's what we want
everyone wants freedom of course but if
you want to have freedom in your life
the way to get to freedom is is through
discipline it's that's how you get there
so if you want to be if you want to be
financially free you have to have
financial discipline you have to save
your money you have to work hard to earn
more money you have to not buy by stupid
things that you don't actually need
right you need to save that money and
invest it properly if all that takes
discipline and if you have that kind of
discipline you'll end up with more
freedom if you want to be if you wanna
have more free time everybody wants more
free time but if you want more free time
how are you gonna get it you have to
have more discipline time management
rule number two step out of your comfort
zone I'm a chef in a large operation
kitchen recently during my last review I
was given some advice by my boss and his
boss they said it was important for me
to give up some of my kitchen dal
mentality and work to showcase my
artistic side and embrace more of a star
role in the spotlight get out of the
kitchen a bit more gain more exposure
specifically with our high-profile
clients should I heed their advice or
stick to what I do best and keep getting
after it on my terms just funny how how
that last statement is framed right yeah
I stick to what I do best and keep
getting after it as if to say if you say
no you should not stick to what you do
best it's like you should not get after
it right that's that's the frame there
and actually this guy I answered the
question real tersely I think this came
through Facebook messages so you know I
said sounds like you found a comfortable
little zone for yourself and you want to
stay in there right response and he's
like I knew it because as we know in the
comfort zone ders there's no growth in
the confidence good if you really don't
want to do it well then you can keep
being the guy that's in the back and
guess what you're gonna be mad in six
months when some other chef gets hired
for a different shift and all of a
sudden he's out making friends with
everyone he gets promoted and why does
he get promoted well look what the guys
doing but he's not as good as he's not
as good as a cook as I am guess what
they don't really care hmm being making
the food is only part of what they want
you to do just like being a seal doing
the doing missions is only part of what
they what you need to do to do the
mission yeah you can't just be
tactically sound you've got to have the
relationships built so you can work in
the battlespace that's owned by a
conventional commander you got to have
the relationship that you can get your
missions approved up the chain of
command all the Special Operations side
how do you do that you build you go out
you talk to people you get out of your
comfort zone rule number three stop
lying to yourself we lie to ourselves we
don't tell ourselves the way things
really are and when we do that then we
can't fix our problems if we can't fix
our problems we're not going to improve
so we have to be truthful to ourselves I
have to be truthful to myself you have
to be truthful to yourself you have to
stop rationalizing stop making excuses
stop telling yourself little water down
assessments of where you're really at
tell yourself the truth so that you can
get where you want to go you can be who
you want to be you could be who you
should be who you should be when you do
what you know you should do when you pay
attention to the little things when you
implement discipline true and
unflinching and unmitigated discipline
in your life when you stop when you stop
trying to find a sweat list solution
when you look for weaknesses to work on
when you allow no easy excuses and all
that starts when you stop lying to
yourself and you stop lying to yourself
that's when you can become who you know
you should be when you tell yourself the
truth about where you are so you can
make sure you are in the right place and
if you're not in the right place then
you can get yourself on the path to get
there the path of discipline the path of
hard work and the path of truth written
before talk less say more I have been
somewhat of a pushover for the majority
of my life since listening to the
podcast I've been trying to assert
myself more one thing I can't seem to
shake is constantly being interrupted
how can I rise above and overcome this
obstacle so when I'm in a group of
people that all want to talk and I want
to talk over each other and they want to
cut each other off you get in that group
right there
III don't talk yeah I don't talk I let
their sigh I sit there I listen to him
and i plot then I think and I put
together my thoughts correctly
so that when I do decide to say
something it's going to have impact hmm
and then I wait for the right moment
right because if there's people could
have it going back and forth I wait for
a lull in the fire and when that Lo
comes then I make my point in a very
direct manner
I might even I might even have to wait
until the conversation is like all but
over
hmm wait till they're done with their
little fire fight yep yep yep yep yep
yep yep yep yep yep yep and then I'm
gonna talk you're done
and what I when I talk you know I'm
gonna do it since I've been thinking
about it's gonna be articulated in a way
that I can present my full point and I
so I think that's an effective way to do
things I think I think if you let people
speak a bunch you let them get it out of
their system and then when you decide to
talk they don't have anything left to
say so that's a way to stop getting cut
off so this is almost like flanking
right this is flanking the fact that
when people have a bunch to say and they
got all these thoughts in their head and
they want to get them all out let them
get them out don't try and fight that
battle they've got a bunch of things
they want to say let them say it all so
as we know when you listen to someone
else talk it you you now know what their
ideas are yeah you know what they're
thinking there's a power and not saying
anything because it allows you to think
and it allows you to hear what other
people think and it allows you to hear
other people so in a conversation you
get to hear other people's counters to
what people are saying now you're not
you're not having to expend any
ammunition yourself someone else is
doing it you know the the third or
fourth or fifth piece person the
conversation that's expending ammunition
and running their mouth to try and solve
encounter some point that someone made
let them do that because by the way then
you get to see what the other counter is
hmm so I think being assertive doesn't
mean talking more I think being
assertive means talking less talking at
the appropriate times monitoring and
understanding the fire fight that's
happening so that
when other people have expended their
ammunition you can step in and you can
take your shots you in a simple clear
concise manner here's another thing it's
like the little boy that cried wolf
right if I if I talk and talk and talk
and talk and talk I'm taking away the
value of each one of those statements
that I'm in because I'm making so many
statements that not all of them can have
a high level of value so well who do you
who do you pay more attention to the
person that makes a hundred statements
yeah and what are those okay let's say
you want to pay attention the person
that makes a hundred statements how much
can you pay attention to those hundred
statements how much do you how much do
you gather from those hundred statements
yeah it's it's a limited amount yeah
it's one percent per statement right
what's one your said you have to feel
you think I make some ends dated one
percent per statement if the person says
one thing how much percent do you pay
attention that on that's right present
rule number five keep things in
perspective when we deployed to Iraq in
2006 we'd been fighting since 2003 and
we'd had very few casualties in the SEAL
Teams the amount of guys that had
experienced their teammates killed in
action was minuscule and so there was no
preparation other than what I had taken
away from reading about combat for my
old life and what I did was what I knew
how to do which was work and and that's
literally what I told my guys was we've
we've crossed a line and there's no
there's no possible way to replace or
describe or overcome the amount of just
heart wrenching sadness that you feel
when you lose a teammate I didn't know
what to do and I didn't know what to say
first time first time second time third
time irrelevant put time I think that
understanding history and reading and
knowing how people have gone through
this before just the fact that you know
when we
we had a small number of casualties you
know we lost three guys from task unit
bruiser each one of them is an epic loss
to us and to humanity and at the same
time in World War two in World War one
there would be days where thousands upon
thousands were killed and so that
offered me a small bit of perspective to
think to myself that human beings we can
feel like we're special and we can feel
like no one's ever been through what
I've been through and the world is hard
for me and easier for everyone else well
the reality is that's not true and we're
not special and the things that people
go through other people have gone
through most likely much much worse and
much more significant so that to me was
a it gave me at least some level of
perspective to realize that other
warriors had gone through this before
this was my turn and this is how I'm
gonna try and handle it
rule number six build relationships I'm
kind of anti-social right like if you
don't know me we're not gonna have a
conversation you know like we're not
having it I'm like it's not I'm not I'm
not walking up and talking to you if I
don't know you I'm not walking up and
saying hi to you it's not happening it's
not my personality if you say hi to me
I'll say hi I'm not disrespectful I'm
not rude but I'm not looking to have a
bunch of conversations with people and
so that's known to me but that's not
okay for the business side of my life
which is hey I gotta talk to people
gotta build relationships gotta had to
know my commanding officer had to know
the Commodore had to know the the the
conventional battalion commander had to
know the brigade commander had to build
relationships could I just talk about
the war with the brigade commander well
I could but what's more powerful that I
talk about war and I talk about where
I'm from or where he's from or what you
know no other things yes because I want
to build a relationship but why because
I'm trying to build trust Awad
why because I wanted to allow me to go
out there and do things in his battle
space
rule number seven have goals sometimes
even if you're the most highly motivated
person in the world that grind starts to
beat you down a little bit and that's
when you have to stop looking at the
short-term thing because that's not
that's not getting you to get it done
and you got to look okay what is the
long-term goal that I'm looking at what
am I really trying to get done in the
long term and you say oh you know what
I'm actually waking up today early so I
can be ahead of the curve so I can sell
more of these widgets or whatever so
right I can buy a house and you know
what today matters today matters this
decision that I'm making right now is
that first step it's me taking one
stroke swimming in the right direction
heading towards the shore and if I don't
take this I'm not making any progress
rule number eight have balance something
I realized so as Lafe and I have been
talking about why we wrote the book the
dichotomy of leadership why we pick that
topic and what we've been saying is most
of the questions that we would get asked
would be about that economy of
leadership that's completely true but
I'll tell you on top of that more
important most of the answers that I
give are that there's a dichotomy in
leadership and you need to be balanced
that is what you even today I got asked
at camp hey Jocko I'm a white belt but I
want to be default aggressive but I also
hear you tell me to relax all the time
which one is it what do you want me to
do should I be default aggressive and
get after ya or you tell me relax and I
actually you know I say relax harder
right you wanna relax for a bit which
one do you want me to do and I said well
luckily and Leif's they're doing like
left luckily for this very reason later
I just wrote a book called the dichotomy
of leadership and there's a dichotomy
with aggression even though I say
default aggressive and I say you go
that's got to be your mindset that's got
to be a default Buddhist you're gonna be
aggressive but you're gonna go get after
it and there's a chapter in the book you
that doesn't mean that you run to your
death right you have to balance that
with caution with with energy
conservation with not wasting movement
on the mat with not wasting capital in
business without burning bridges like
those things you have to be balanced
rule number nine be open-minded
obviously you were commander on a unit
you were not a bat battalion commander
you were a commander still you have
people that are reporting to constantly
how can you differentiate between
somebody that could be a leader of your
universe is somebody that needs a lot of
hand-holding with their trends that you
saw where there's certain things that
you were looking at again this is one of
those things where I mean you know you
can look at a person you can do an
assessment and I do pretty good with my
assessment you've been in business for a
long time you you do pre you in the army
you know you do pretty good with your
assessment but you're you're only baton
60 said how many times you've hired
somebody thought was gonna knock it out
of the park and two months later you end
up firing them hey long live
it's a long list right how many times
you've yeah you know what I'll give a
guy a shot and then they end up being a
great person you know you get right some
of the times you know probably 60 70
percent of the time maybe even more but
you definitely can't guarantee anything
and that's why I look at everyone with
an open mind I look at people in open
mind so not only do you know I want you
to be humble if you want to learn but
I'm looking at you with an open mind I'm
not looking at you putting you in a box
and thinking oh he doesn't really have
this capability I'm looking like okay
let's hope he has the capability and if
he does we're gonna build on it we're
gonna turn them into into into a solid
leader and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
don't snooze don't press snooze snooze
doesn't help but loses one of those
things that just series a throme killer
yeah it's like a snooze bar area more
that's that's right yeah it's like a
complete think it's gonna help you dream
more but it's not the story it's a full
psychological trick if you must lose
the thing that you've been pressing the
snooze helps you with like I'll just get
that extra eight minutes to sleep that
eight minutes the sleep ability to be
anywhere energy by the way 18 seconds
there's there's an 18 second window in
the morning when your alarm goes off
that sucks
it's about 18 seconds so 18 that the
alarm goes off that you touch it then
the next 18 seconds are like hard there
that's when you have to use maximum
effort to clear the gravitational pull
of your pillow
if you can get away from those 18
seconds then you're okay you just get up
get away from the pillow and it's
pulling you in some tractor beam I'm
gonna get away from that and so that 18
seconds and once you're up and moving
you're good
now I've got a special bonus clip from
Jocko and how to make good decisions
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life for
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one will you
commit to not snoozing number two what
do you need to do a better job of
keeping an open mind about and number
three what does balance look like for
you
the skill itself is being able to detach
during the event the heartburn is to
notice you gotta look for those signs
you gotta look for that moment when you
start feeling emotional or you know that
it's gonna be something emotional you've
got a step back from those and get get
yourself in the habit of asking yourself
what do I look like right now
what do I sound like right now listen to
the words that are coming out of your
mouth and see if you're being a
reasonable Cuban or not look for the
emotional quicksand and don't step in
that the emotional they anger the
frustration when you start feeling the
sweat beating up when you start feeling
hot that should be a big red flag there
it is that's the quicksand of emotion
you don't want to step into
self back
if you want more Jocko willing check at
the top 50 rules of success video I mean
I'm hearing the link is right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there don't
think anymore don't plan anymore don't
contemplate anymore don't make any more
excuses